komplett dänemark wurde in minecraft
nachgebaut meine lieben freunde
löw meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft facts heute am mittwoch
eigentlich sollten sie gestern am
dienstag kommen aber dass ich keine zeit
deswegen hab ich da die kräftigen
hochgeladen ich freue mich dass sie
wieder mit dabei sein und ich glaube ich
werde auch mal eben die feste so ein
bisschen so an damit ich mit ihm
mittiger drin bin ich war friseur
ich habe 4 mm undercut jetzt ich werde
es nie wieder so so kurz machen das ist
echt ja ist schon fucking kurz aber ich
dachte so sommer ja kurze haare
es ist märz jedenfalls wurden mir wieder
für zisch schlug mir würden wieder
extrem viele kühe zugesendeten effekt
wurde mir zugesendet und da hinten ist
das bio mit viel schöner mir wurden
wieder fünf fag zugesendet
beziehungsweise ganz viel effekt
zugesendet ich habe mir fünf rausgesucht
und die werde ich euch jetzt vorstellen
wir waren die regale mit beck nummer ihr
seht hier schon so einen provisorischen
kasten von mir aufgebaut und zwar ist
dort drin nur wasser und da kann man
natürlich raus schwimmen als minecraft
mensch zumindest aber ein gas kann das
nicht guck mal mit dem schiller sieht
man ja gar nicht dass hier ist ja glas
ist das crazy jedenfalls ihr seht schon
ich könnte hier einfach irgendwo raus
fliegen also hier oben beispielsweise
ein gas kann das nicht weil ein gast ist
wenn ich jemand gastein setzte seht ihr
schon wie groß ein gastes und zwar ein
gast ist ja im netz aktiv und im neckar
gibt es kein wasser
deswegen habe ich mich mehr so gefragt
ertrinken gast eigentlich weil dir
eigentlich nie mit wasser in berührung
kommen und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
mal ein gast einfach hier unten rein
setzte so damit ein gas drin hier
und wenn wir das jetzt sehen ich werde
dann angerufen aber ihr seht schon hier
der gast ihr hört schon die komischen
jetzt heim auf mich anzurufen
die hört schon die komischen kunst wird
der schaden bekommen
und jetzt ist der tod das heißt gas
ertrinken unter wasser obwohl sie quasi
im netz gar nicht mit dem wasser
wirklich in berührung kommen die nicht
ein bisschen eigenartig irgendwie weil
ich meinen also natürlich wenn sie in
wasser rein kommen und sie können auch
wieder raus dann schwimmen sie auch
wieder raus oder sie verhalten sich so
wie fledermäuse das war ganz behindert
einfach die fledermäuse hat mir einen
anderen crafting infolge der ortschaft
wie so komme ich immer an mit dem
kräftigen den heute hatten wir ja eine
andere folge da sind die fledermäuse
dann einfach wie umhergeflogen und dem
wahrscheinlich alles hier trinken aber
wenn ich einen gas beispielsweise hier
einfach mal in diesem käfig hier ein
sportler wenn ich dann hier auch wieder
rauskomme sie schon der gast steckt in
der wand fest sollen wir einfach mal
neun hier so der neue ist auf jeden fall
hier im wasser drin ihr seht schon der
kommt hier nirgends uhr aus hier oben
wird da auch nicht aus kann man das sind
nur zwei mal zwei felder und da oben bei
dem zwei mal drei einig und nach einer
gewissen zeit hörte dann schon dass der
gas komische sounds von sich gibt und
dann stirbt er einfach das ist fakt
nummer eins und wir machen weiter mit
fact nummer zwei für den fake nummer
zwei muss ich mir erst mal eben kurz
eine feuerwerksrakete machen und zwar
wenn ich diese feuerwerksrakete jetzt in
einen dispens apag und irdischen der
dispenser zeigt nach unten und nicht
nach oben dann seht ihr nämlich schon
eigentlich wird er dann das alte nach
unten raus geschmissen das wird es auch
allerdings irak moment wartet die rakete
wird nach unten raus geschmissen geht
allerdings dann durch den dispenser
durch und schießt in den himmel das
finde ich ein bisschen schade dass
raketen im anschluss einfach nur nach
oben fliegen weil ich finde gerade wenn
man sie eigentlich in einen dispenser
packt sollten sie nach unten fliegen
können ich meine es ist einem echten
leben auch so durch eine rakete inhalte
liegt ihr auch hin und freunde fast nie
raketen mit der bloßen hand an ich habe
mir schon mal richtig bei weh getan ich
glaube das ist auch so eine sache das
muss man einfach mal machen sonst hatte
man die kinder genauso wie beim
fußballspielen
irgendwie sich die kläger auf schiffen
oder irgendwie sind so sein muss man
einfach malen oder schokoladen
zigaretten im mund tun das so tun als
wäre echte zigaretten oder irgendwie
sowas oder dem geschwisterkind sagen hey
wenn sich verletzt hat aber bitte nicht
nochmal sagen ich gebe dir auch das 108
aber da trifft wieder zu sehr ab das ist
auf jeden fall weg nummer zwei wenn ich
eine feuerwerksrakete in einen dispens
attacke der nach unten zeigt dann fliegt
die rakete erst nach unten erst fliegt
die rakete nach unten und danach fliegt
sie dann wieder durch den ist besser
durch in den himmel und explodierte dann
ganz oben zu einem wunderschönen
feuerwerk das ist fakt nummer zwei und
wir machen weiter mit fact nummer drei
für fett nummer drei habe ich hier schon
eine wunderbare konstruktion aufgebaut
und zwar setze ich hier einfach mal
einen amboss hin und ihr seht schon wenn
ich gleich diese leitung aktivieren
dann zieht der dicke pisten den erd-
blog zurück und der amboss fällt nach
unten durch das wasser durch in mich
rein weil ich werde mich gleiche
reinstellen allerdings werde ich mich
nicht hier reinstellen sondern ihr seht
schon das geht ein bisschen runter wenn
ihr mal so schaut das geht ein bisschen
runter also ich werde nach unten schönen
leuten ist sogar noch einen amboss vom
test vorhin also ich werde jetzt erst
mal kurz in den game mode null gehen und
dem ist ja normalerweise wenn mich ein
amboss trifft wenig tod werden also
zumindest aus der höhe zumindest das
sind irgendwie zehn blöcke oder sogar
wenig locker tot wenn ich allerdings
setzt man hier auf druck und die
schwimme währenddessen nach unten seht
ihr der amboss fällt durch mich hindurch
ich denke das hat man ganz gut gesehen
ich schwimme hier wieder hoch ich mal
kurz im gaylord 1 und zwar da manchmal
eben hier die beiden ambosse weg gemacht
dass man immer noch ein bisschen tiefer
und zwar geht das nur wenn also der fei
gesagt wenn ich runter schwimme und ein
amboss trifft mich dann während ich
runter schwimme dann wie kriege ich
keinen schaden davon wenn ich allerdings
jetzt beispielsweise mal ich weiß nicht
ob es jetzt gerade auch noch so ist oder
ob es gerade daran lag dass ich in
anderen versionen war allerdings wenig
hoch schwimmer also ich bin jetzt mal
hoch und drückte jetzt mal den schalter
so dann seht ihr
doch auch wenn ich hochschule geht auch
der lachs von der version nur wenn ich
in dem wasser drin stehe dann bekomme
ich den schaden also das heißt
beispielsweise ich mache jetzt mal
einfach so setzte ich hier einfach mal
so ein blog in mario wieder alles so
dass es läuft setzt sich oben ein amboss
sehen so zac und gehe jetzt mal in den
game mode so ich bin jetzt hier im game
mode 0
alle mich mal hier rein und drücke den
schalter und ihr seht schon dann von
crafter wurde von einem fallenden
ambosse quetscht das heißt rein
theoretisch wenn ihr von einem amboss
getroffen werdet macht euch schnell
wasser und schwimmt hoch oder runter
keine ahnung wofür man das jetzt braucht
ist auf jeden fall effekt dass wenn ein
amboss im wasser runter fällt und ich
gerade wasser hoch schwimme oder runter
schwimmen auf jeden fall in bewegung bin
dann ist es scheißegal
genauso ist es meine ich auch wenn man
im wenn man im freien modus ist aber
anhalt noch ein game mode nullachse
damals eine modifikation mit der mann
fliegen konnte aber trotzdem noch
schaden bekommen hat und so habe ich
alles kaputt gemacht ich denke ihr wisst
was ich meine wenn man also hoch und
runter irgendwie in bewegung ist oder so
dann bekommt man keinen schaden von
einem fallenden amboss ich denke das
habe ich ganz gut gezeigt wenn jetzt
nicht verstanden habt tut mir leid wenn
ihr zwei standard freue ich mich die
sonne geht hier auch schon wieder unter
das ist das was mir immer die folge
schon zehn minuten lang
zumindest ihren mit der raw dateien wie
man aber direkt wieder mit fake nummer
vier effekt nummer vier ist wieder eine
kleine sache die mit minecraft gerade
mit dem ingame zumindest nicht viel zu
tun hat und zwar das bio ist die
wirklich viel viel schöner das sieht
extrem schön aus hier und zwar ein mann
läuft seit vier jahren durchgehend nach
westen in minecraft das ist courtney mag
der ist insgesamt schon fast 1000
kilometer gewandert und der dokumentiert
jeden einzelnen schritt den er macht auf
seinem youtube kanal fast vor handelt
die serie heißt vollends ob passt also
in etwa entweder wir finden die fans
oder wir machen alles kaputt
also passt heißt so etwas wie kaputt
machen und ihr seht ja gerade schon oben
rechts im bild eingeblendet so sehen die
fans aus und zwar die fans sind einfach
etwas von mojang hinzugefügt wenn man
nämlich in minecraft unendlich weit nach
westen läuft ich meine es sind noch viel
viel mehr kilometer als er letztendlich
schon gelaufen ist er ja schon irgendwie
438 parks oder so gemacht wo er immer
weiter läuft dann trifft man irgendwann
so wende quasi die einfach so komplett
gefüllt sind das hat mich mal so ein
bisschen dieses bild erinnert mich so
ein bisschen
inception wo der an diesem strand
auftauchte komplette strand band einfach
abgefahren oder diese komplette sandwand
einfach abgefallen ist in den sessions
und wenn man sich wenn man diese diese
fans erreicht heißt es halt dass man
dass es keine bio mehr gibt von
minecraft die man willkürlich erstellen
kann also dass man schon so viele bio
mit durchlebt hat beziehungsweise so
viele verschiedene tanks geladen wurden
ich hoffe ich erkläre das richtig nett
wenn das irgendwer irgendwie anders weiß
oder besser weiß als ich dann bitte
einfach in die kommentare schreiben ich
weiß halt nur das was ich selber weiß
und was im blick stehe und was ich auch
mega interessant finde wenn man diese
fan lens erreicht stellen forderten die
fans da wird das spiel immer langsamer
so slow motion mäßig und es ruckelt dann
immer mehr und irgendwann kann es auch
sein dass es dann ab stürzt also
wirklich so ein mysterium ich glaube es
hat noch niemand diese vollends erreicht
weil man dafür wirklich sowas von weit
laufen muss und der cursor mac macht das
auf jeden fall ganz geil der läuft
einfach schon die ganze zeit richtung
westen seit mehreren jahren ist dort
seit vier jahren einfach schon belegt
davon jeden tag ein video hoch wenn ihr
bock habt euch das mal zu schauen ich
habe von stunden video clip davon
eingeblendet sonst einfach mal bei
youtube fans oberste minecraft 1 geben
da werdet ihr das war auch mit
sicherheit fündig werden und das ist
fakt nummer vier und das finde ich mega
interessant dass es solche leute gibt
die sowas machen und ich finde auch
solche facts irgendwie viel
interessanter als facts in game aber das
ist meine persönliche ansicht
ich werde in zukunft immer schauen wie
ich die serie vielleicht ein bisschen
anders gestalten könnte vielleicht nur
drei fix aber dafür dann bessere facts
oder irgend sowas keine ahnung denn
ideen ab in die kommentare und wenn ihr
es habt auch in die kommentare weil
effekts kann man nie genug haben meine
lieben freunde aber mark war damit
perfekt gemacht freunde habe ich mich
dafür entschuldigen muss aber weckt
nummer fünf ist auch etwas was nicht in
minecraft ist aber auch mega mais und
zwar das khat gefunden und zwar habe ich
euch ja schon mal gesagt dass
in schweden teilweise minecraft wirklich
als schulfach genutzt wird wo man halt
wirklich lernen wie die blöcke
funktionieren wie verschiedene formen
aussehen so qualität 3
da steht dann auch da gibt noch kein
internat oder verschiedene sachen
einfach werden minecraft halt als
bildungs bildungszwecke - und zwar auch
als bildungszwecke komplett dänemark
wurde in minecraft nachgebaut meine
lieben freunde komplett dänemark ich
weiß aus landessicht groß aber es ist
komplett nachgebaut worden das wird auch
ausbildungszwecken gemacht weil sich die
dänische politik oder die bis
bildungsministerium oder was weiß ich
wer sich das gedacht hat oder
verschiedene schulen oder so das ist
doch interessant sei wenn die kinder die
spielen ja gerne spiele und so und das
ist vielleicht ein bisschen dass die
etwas an der geografie von dänemark mit
kriegen wenn die da in ihrem eigenen
minecraft spiel durchlaufen können
allerdings haben sich dann so ein paar
rowdies gedacht dänemark gefällt uns
nicht wir gehen einmal hin briefen den
server und platzieren überall
amerikanische flaggen und die sind quasi
einfach wirklich auf dem server gegangen
haben die städte unter die dörfer die
dort nachgebaut wurden also komplett
dänemark mit tnt zersprengt und dort
erhalten über also usa flaggen ihm
platziert da seht ihr halt gerade schon
so ein bild einfach eingeblendet wie das
ganze dann aus was haltet ihr von so was
also was haltet ihr einerseits davon
dass dänemark komplett nachgebaut wurde
also ich finds mega geil weil das hat
quasi heißt dass die regierung bzw
die leute die das halt gemacht haben was
verstehen von der jugend so
beispielsweise die zocken in minecraft
machen wir den unterricht doch da
drinnen oder irgendwie sowas wäre
vielleicht ganz nice einfach mal in
deutschland setzen stückchen größer als
dänemark aber ich finde coole idee nur
das von den von den komischen griefahn
da aus amerika das kann ich
nachvollziehen ich weiß nicht wie man
sowas spaß haben kann wenn man einfach
so sachen kaputt machen kann also ich
verstehe ehrlich gesagt nicht finde ich
traurig aber die idee an sich finde ich
super auch dass es in schweden teilweise
schulfach genutzt wird ist klasse was
haltet ihr von schreiben kommentare und
das war auch schon effekt 05 ja freuen
und das war es dann auch wieder für
diese folge der minecraft es tut mir
leid dass ich so viel die ganzen raum
gehoppelt bin hier und so aber ich mag
es einfach um zu laufen in minecraft
dass mario für die musik oder langeweile
aber einfach
treff ist herumlaufen und würde ich
sagen wenn euch gefallen da würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen dass es
ein klitzekleiner click & facts und
kommentare schreiben und wenn ihr bock
habt könnt ihr dann auch morgen wieder
einschalten oder eine andere folge
anschauen oder irgendwas machen und
damit ihre wunderschönen tag